we set up in the lab a bowl full of
glass beads tiny glass beads that
represents and set up a an apparatus
hold a steel ball-bearing and a height
of a meter above the surface you flicked
a switch the ball dropped down went into
the sand and made a crater the advantage
of using glass is that it's more nearly
spherical or round so it doesn't have
any sharp jagged edges we have two bags
of these downstairs one is the diameter
of a typical bead is about tenth of a
millimeter the other one is point six
four millimeter which you can imagine
because you can see it on a ruler so
that's actually quite a coarse grain so
there's a substantial difference between
these two this is the fine powder the
point 1 millimeter beads you can see it
falling down as if it were water fall
into the tiny bowl and we do this slowly
so that the bowl underneath gets a layer
which is as gently created as possible
it turns out that air has a big effect
we want to trap the air as much as
possible if you don't do it this way if
you stamp it down the whole effect
disappears right this is the the bed of
that point 1 and here comes the little
ball bashing into it and you get a nice
crown appearing as you might expect and
then after this crown dies away a plume
appears in the center of the screen
rising up higher and higher and higher
and then that plume seems to break into
little bits and fall down so you get a
secondary effect of a jet a plume coming
out of this cloud which appears as you
look in sideways now we repeat the
experiment using the bigger beads 0.6
millimeters in it the steel ball comes
in you get
Korona coming out but wait for it there
is no plume nothing rises up from the
center you just get a normal crater
appearing in the glass beads now we're
using the finely grained particles and
the sphere comes down and bashes in and
you can see it more or less from a top
view and it digs a hole blows out a ring
shaped thing and the plume rises from
the center goes up goes up goes up so
you've got a crater circular crater
formed and now as the plume falls down
you get a little dimple or pimple or
whatever you would like to call it now
we're looking at the same experiment for
the larger glass spheres and down comes
the sphere creates a crater a hole in
the middle and now you can see that
there is a slight dimple or pimple in
the middle but nothing came up as a
plume so it's almost the same creating a
very nice crater but the plume has
almost disappeared the bed of sand is
full of air as the seer comes down it
compresses the bed of sand when it hits
the hits it pushes down creates a hole
and all the air in the region that it's
just compressed wants to get out so the
further down this this sphere goes
you've got a little tube coming up and
that the air trying to escape wants to
go out that tube so you get after a
little while a blast of air coming up
through this tube sad can fall into this
tube from the sides and it gets carried
away with the wind that's blowing
upwards so if these particles are tiny
they get swept up by this gust of wind
if the particles are heavy they don't
get swept along so easily and that's the
reason why they don't really blow up you
can see a little bit because they might
have been blown up tiny amount but they
don't go way up into the air
so the finer the particles are
the more they gonna get carried up by
this blast of air where did that air
come from was that the air that was
between the potluck under the ball now
yes directly under the ball because as
it comes down it pushes and pushes these
particles together and compresses them
and that air wants to escape somehow and
the only place you can go is up in go
sideways but you do get this jet what's
causing this is the air and the proof of
that is the experiment was set up by a
group led by Jagger in Chicago a very
respected group and they decided to do
it in a completely sealed container so
the bowl is in the container the ball is
in the container and is cut off from the
rest of the world and they could pump
out the air when the air is there the
effect is present by reducing the
pressure of the air sufficiently they
can make the effect go away if you'd
like to see more on this subject
including Worthington Jets when objects
hit a water surface I'd really recommend
Destin's video over at smarter every day
be warned there's a little bit of toilet
humor but he's from Alabama also I
recently made a video about what I think
when people write first in the comment
section on YouTube you can have a look
at that if you like and if you just want
more slow motion where we're doing a lot
of it at periodic videos with chemistry
videos at the moment I'll also include a
link to that on the screen I imagine I
don't know yet but I imagine it'll be
below me and to the side in a box down
there I don't know I sort of do this
afterwards but you get the idea and of
course all these links will also be in
the description under the video